Les réunions
chez Microsoft
Aaaaaaah!
Ah bah voilà!
C'est ça, on en parle après la pause dèj
et on s'en va comme ça c'est plus simple
Aie
Ehmmm
Phfrrrrrrrrrrr
Ça c'est très bien
*Claquement de porte*
Thhhhhhhh
Ha ha ha ha
C'est bon mon gars
*Claquement de porte*
Thhhhhhhhhh
Chez IKEA
Sinon on met des voyelles?
TA GUEULE !
Arrête tes conneries, là OH!
Allez
Putain!
aller,  ramasse
Rhoooooh
Mais c'est... Euhhhh
C'est pas facile
Pfff ho ha ha ha ha ha ha
Chez HARIBO
Les mecs, c'est bon, j'ai lancé la
HA HA HA HA HA HA
euah! euah!
Chez YouTube
YouTube, première
*Clap Clap*
-Il rajoute...
-C'est vrai que je suis parti...
-Euh Tu l'a pas bien eu hein !
C'est vrai que je suis parti un peu speed...
*Clap*
*Clap Clap*
Aller, on y va
Ah Ah
Et action.
*Clap*
Action ?
Ouais *Clap*
*Clap*
*Ouverture porte*
Allez on y va.
*Rires*
Chez YouTube
Mon chéri voici...oh putain...
*Rires*
Bébé voici la liste des YouTubers Français.
*Pouffement*
Bébé voici la liste des YouTubers Fran...
*Rires*
Chez Nintendo
Allez ! ... Allez ! ... Allez ! ... Allez !
Allez !
*Pouffement*
*Rires*
Mais c'est un...
Définition du seum.
à la RATP
*Musique d’accordéon*
*Rires*
Non mais je te regarde Julien t'es mort de rire. Je veux pas bouger. Je le vois au bort de la...
Moi ?!
*Rires*
Chez NRJ 12
Les anges de la télé-réalité à Meudun ?
Déjà fait.
*Rires*
À Meudun ?!
-À Meudun ?!
-Sinon Meudun ... Allez Meudun, bas les couilles !
*Rires*
Chez Free
Le prix tombe à 16€ !
OOHHH !!!
Et oui !
*Rires*
J'y attendais pas à celle et...
OOHHH !!! Et OUI !
ET OUI !!!
*Rires*
Oooohh. Et oui !
-Et oui
-Et oui-oui l'école est finie !
*Rires*
C'est mon idée.
Ma femme me dit...
Allez ! Madison !
Hain.
Elle s'appelle Madison la femme de Didier ?
Je...
Hain ! Tain tain tain tain tain ...
Madison !
*Rires*
Chez Orange
Ouaaaa !
*Cling*
Chez Absolut Vodka
J'ai vomi ... J'ai vo... J'ai vomi sur...
Je sais !! ... Je sais !
J'ai vomi sur la table ... sur la table du salon de ma Mère.
Chez Avast
La base virale VPS a été mise ...
Tope là ! Ça a marché !
Ça m'as l'air...
C'est pas mal hein ?
Le prénom de la dame !
C'est quoi votre prénom ?
Flavione
Enchanté Flavione !
C'était très bien !
Les réunions...
Chez Snapchat
C'est quand même dommage que toutes les photos soient supprimées.
Mais non je les aient toutes, moi !
Quoi ?!
Ding ça !
OOOHH !!
Huumm !
Oauaa ! Putain !!
Chez Beats
Est-ce que 400€ le casque ça sent l'arnaque ?
UUUffff ??
Chez Technikart
-Gravity ?!
-Les gens vont adorés !
Ils vont détest' !
Et ouais...
Le dernier Coldplay ?
C'est un bide !
C'est l'album de l'année ! On peut le dire !
Bravo à vous !
-Merci ! Au revoir !
-Bon travail !
Merci !
Chez Beats
Ils achètent ! Ils a...
Ok est-ce que 600€ les écouteurs ça sent l'arnaque ?
Uuuffff ??
Chez YouPorn
-Les gars j'ai un peu de boulot à rattraper là.
-Oui
-Je dois filer.
-Ça tombe bien moi aussi.
-Allez ! Au revoir !
-Oui oui oui
-Bien sûr !
-Au revoir
-Salut !
-Salut ! À plus tard !
Boulot boulot en ce moment ... un ... parce que là ...
Allez !
-Le pistolet à eau !!!
-Le coussin péteur !!!
Non ! Non ! Non ! On bat pas !
On bat pas ! Arrêtez !!
Stop !
STOP !!
Non ! NOOONN !! NON !!!
Non !
Je ... Qu'est-ce que j'ai dit ? !!!